okay so that moment when you guys come
out there that was bananas Daisy I mean
that's a real rock star yeah it is I'm
like this is what it feels like to be
ariana grande but not really because
she's literally doing it all by herself
was a bittersweet though knowing you're
standing out there with all your
comrades and this is the last yeah well
it was weird cuz as we came off I
thought oh oh but this is the last time
we're gonna be doing this as a group
yeah both so I'm just really excited for
the film it's like come on and then when
it's the film's I'm like no comeback
yeah it's so strange so the headline
I've seen is has Daisy Ridley gone to
the dark side because in the footage
you're holding a red light I am okay
Daisy Ridley is like I believe her right
ray well yeah I do hold the red saber
what do you think it's the end why not
exactly why not why and why not
everybody has a dark side exactly
everybody has it outside and we see this
battle in this character and it was very
fun to play and it will be very fun to
watch
[Applause]
[Music]